welcome to the NewsHour we begin in
Russia where police have launched a
murder investigation after the daughter
of a pro-kremlin commentator was killed
in a car bomb explosion near Moscow
unverified social media footage showed
Daria dogina's father Alexander at the
scene shortly after the bombing both
have supported Russia's invasion of
Ukraine
well Alexander Dugan is a Russian
philosopher political analyst and
strategist he was the chief editor at
the pro Kremlin
TV station Dugan was reportedly helped
or shaped Vladimir Putin's expansionist
foreign policies and has been called
often Putin's brain he was involved in
the Russian president's Initiative for
the annexation of Crimea and considered
the invasion of Ukraine inevitable Dugan
has previously called for the
eradication of Ukrainian identity
well Samuel Romani is an associate
fellow at the Royal United Services
Institute and joins me now from Oxford
in England good to have you with us on
the program sir I mean can we make the
assumption that the target might have
been Alexander Dugan rather than his
daughter
AG is very likely that the target was
Alexander Dugan rather than his daughter
I think that even though Jerry dugina
has his bows very similar views to her
father Vicki Lee accusing the west of
committing Nazism calling for the
annexation of all of Ukraine with the
exception of levied and the
self-cleansing aversion society and her
influences drastically less than her
father's well I mean who would be the
likely suspects because uh both uh the
Kremlin and Ukraine are saying it's not
them but behind the scenes was Alexander
Dugan universally popular within Russia
and specifically within the Kremlin
so all I got to do because actual
influence over Russian policy has been
grossly overstated I reject the claims
that he is Putin's Rasputin or Putin's
brain which is often the title that's
been given him to the Western media in
fact he never really held an official
title within Russia and his closest
Partners within the crownland are people
like Serena Glazier who were dismissed
from the Kremlin in 2019 isn't that in
touch with the current establishment
well at least of all Putin so I don't
think it's really a strike at a major
Russian foreign policy decision maker of
course the Russian deployment Ministry
is blaming that Ukraine for this saying
that it's part of a pattern of Ukrainian
terrorist activity which extends the
attacks on Crimea chemical terrorism and
now nuclear terrorism and of course
zelenski's team is saying that Ukraine
is not a terrorist State and doesn't
commit crimes like this so both sides
are denying it I think it's very
unlikely that this was done to derail or
disrupt Russian policy in any way so you
say that he doesn't have that much
influence in Russia but he was more
assertive in terms of trying to make the
campaign for Ukraine uh more on a war
footing compared to the words that we've
heard from the Kremlin and from Putin
talking about a special military
operation their themes seem to diverge
uh to a certain extent what are we to
read into that
so you could have always been December
gray a Hardline nationalist predict a
Russian foreign policy basically wanting
to go much further than Putin is willing
to go in 2008 he wanted uh Russia not to
stop in southern city over they invaded
Georgia they actually go all the way to
tiblicity overthrow zakish Villi and
then the next Crimea in 2014 he wanted
the Russians to officially uh declare
war on Ukraine and next uh most of the
eastern part of the country now he's
calling for a general mobilization uh
draft conscription and the complete uh
movement until the historic Destiny of
Moscow and here have been United
together is a change so he's always been
pushing for more Hardline views than the
Kremlin has called for us that's nothing
new there's no doubt that they have a
line of communication both Dugan and and
Putin but this killing will rattle the
Kremlin in some shape or form won't it
well we'll run out of the crowdland if
it was done by an external Saboteur but
it won't rattle the Kremlin so much if
this was some kind of an internal power
struggle within the Russian Security
Services between people who are trying
to quash intellectuals like Dugan who
might fan the Flames for a faster into
the war I'm more efficient end of the
war or even support for the draft which
is something that the Russians don't
want to do they want to get as many
volunteers as possible they're even
clearing people out of Prisons but they
don't want to do conscription so if it's
done if it's something internal it won't
necessarily rattle the problem but if it
proves to be something external like the
foreign Ministry is Flaming or Ukrainian
related then yes it's certainly what
some of Romani joining us there from
Oxford thank you so much
thank you